for Charlize she adopted her second
child August last summer so it's big
brother Jackson who's adjusting he was
very specific about it he's like it has
to be a sister month they're not to be a
sister and I was like you that's not
really how it works like you're gonna
and get what you get and you don't get
upset and so when we got the good news
that it was a little girl we were he was
really really happy and then he went can
I now have a brother and I was like oh
all the kids were regulars on the set of
the Huntsman winters war
Chris Hemsworth and his wife Elsa's
three-year-old daughter indiarose loved
watching Jessica Chastain in action the
other thing about my daughter watching
characters like this where they can lead
armies and you've been charged on
destiny and I think I'm great that's
what I want her to think is possible not
you know being rescued by the Prince but
what about those steamy love scenes and
how does it feel when your significant
other is watching them in whatever is it
wasn't a true love kiss it wasn't acting